bands are mourning the passing of Cindy
Williams who starred in one of TV's most
memorable sitcoms and left a lasting
Legacy on January 25th 2023 the
entertainment World lost a comedy Legend
at the age of 75 Laverne and Shirley
star Cindy Williams died in Los Angeles
California following a brief unspecified
illness as revealed by her children Zach
and Emily Hudson who said in a statement
through their family spokeswoman the
passing of Our Kind hilarious mother
Cindy Williams has brought us
insurmountable sadness that could never
truly be expressed knowing and loving
her has been our joy and privilege her
social media team also announced her
passing by Instagram television viewers
will likely remember Williams best for
her work as Shirley Feeney on Laverne
and Shirley a spin-off of Happy Days her
efforts and those of her co-star Penny
Marshall turned the program from a mere
offshoot to a genuine small screen
classic additionally Williams became a
household name thanks to her work in
films such as American Graffiti its
sequel more American Graffiti and the
conversation among other cinematic
favorites Cindy Williams left a lasting
impact on the entertainment world that
will endure well into the future to
honor her memory in Hollywood Legacy
here's a brief look back at some of the
highlights of her incredible life Cindy
Williams was born in Los Angeles
California on August 22 1947 and it
didn't take her long to realize her
calling in life as she told the archive
of American television she learned at a
young age that she had a gift for comedy
even being voted funniest female by her
peers in high school naturally this led
her to pursue a career in entertainment
whether earning her first of many
professional acting credits in the 1970s
1973 brought her to director George
Lucas's American Graffiti and two years
after that she landed the role of
Shirley Feeney on Happy Days changing
her life trajectory forever nice to meet
you Richie my pleasure Williams only
portrayed Feeney on Happy Days for a
mere five episodes before she and Penny
Marshall kicked off Laverne and Shirley
in 1976. the Beloved sitcom about the
titular friends living life in the 1950s
and 60s stuck around until 1983 and
accumulated 178 episodes not to mention
it was nominated for numerous Awards in
its time including a prime time Emmy in
1979 for outstanding costume design for
a series the show even landed Williams a
Golden Globe nomination in 1978 for best
actress in a television series comedy or
musical it's no secret that Laverne and
Shirley is the production Cindy Williams
is most widely remembered for but she
continued acting long after the show
concluded as far as television credits
go she added the likes of normal life
getting by and even a lone episode of
Law and Order Special Victims Unit to
her expansive resume in terms of movies
she featured in Bingo and still waiting
in the wings to name a few her final
film released before her death is 2020's
Kanan land all in all it's plain to see
that Williams followed her dream and
made the most of it carving out an
entertainment career worth being proud
of during an appearance on the Allison
interviews podcast in December 2021 she
made it clear that she did exactly what
she was meant to do and she's more than
happy with the outcome I was meant to do
exactly what I did that was my service
that is what God sent me here to do I
honestly believe that God steered me in
the direction of Comedy to make people
laugh and make people laugh she did even
though she's gone her work on Laverne
and Shirley Happy Days and more will
continue to entertain audiences for
years to come she will be sorely missed
[Music]